welcome to metaphysical milkshake i am
one of your hosts reza aslan
and i am the other one of your hosts
rayne wilson hi reza hey rayne i got a
question for you did you
yeah ever think when you were young you
know a young impressionable
kid growing up in the pacific northwest
yes do you ever think that one day
you would be doing
a podcast about existential questions
with reza aslan i mean
did that dream ever occur to you
my dream came true
i'm doing a podcast about life's biggest
philosophical spiritual and
psychological questions
with
raza aslan b reza aslan i mean this is
the pinnacle
of your journey welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
truth be told you're onto something with
this question because
from the get-go
i always wanted to be an actor i don't
know why i was just in my dna literally
my mom had been an actor but i had i
just wanted to act more than anything in
the world but
i also wanted to dig into life's biggest
possible questions more than anything in
the world i always loved um deep
conversations i always loved
pondering like what happens when we die
and trying to imagine what infinity was
you know wondering if i had free will
wondering like how and why emotions
worked the way they did just kind of
like what makes human beings tick why do
we do what we do where are we headed as
a species etc the list goes on and on so
the fact that
i was able to kind of transition
my acting life of being like uh which
ended up being kind of the silly sitcom
actor and i was able to transition that
into
soul pancake here it is for those of you
just listening i'm showing off my soul
pancake t-shirt um
uh to dig into life's biggest possible
questions and end up
i'm currently writing a book about
spirituality
and uh having these conversations with
you and the caliber of the guests that
we've had i mean
it's
it's amazing it really is
a dream come true and
um it's kind of like
joseph campbell says follow your bliss
it was kind of like i got to follow a
double bliss because my
my true bliss
is um
is really uh digging into life's biggest
and most perplexing
questions and
having um
elevated distinctive inspiring
conversations about the human experience
so
um
it's like you took quite a very
circuitous route
yeah this is that's not this place it's
not point a to point b to go like go do
a do go do a sitcom where you play a
weird paper salesman and this will allow
you then to meet with oprah and uh
start a uh
a digital media company and and a
podcast that deals with life's biggest
questions um it's not the normal route
you have searched the world for other
comedians you won't find many that went
on this same path but i would say for
you too
you know there's aspects of your story
uh your journey that are just so kind of
inspiring and kind of frankly puzzling
and weird that you have
two master's degrees a phd you studied
creative writing you studied theology
you studied sociology um
and uh you know a religious scholar
like this transition for you
how did how did this work how did you
come to be having these discussions with
me and and the same discussions you've
had on various shows on cable tv and
other podcasts
vis-a-vis
going to divinity school
well i mean it's weird but like this was
the plan all along
you know uh
all my life
this is kind of what i wanted to do like
if you had asked me
you know at the age of 13
what do you want to do with your life i
would have said public intellectual
which is absurd obviously
right
it is a public intellectual isn't that
like socrates he was just a guy who gets
paid to think out loud
like that was like is that a job i'm i'm
sure that's a it was a job in the
victorian era
did you make a dream a dream board with
that a guy who gets paid to think out
loud like how does that i just don't
understand look i guess the process the
past i think the truth is is that
probably so you had to you had immigrant
parents i thought you've talked about
this before they thought it was just
absurd that you want to be a writer yeah
why you want to be writer you can you'll
be writing on the side value our doctor
well that's kind of exactly what my mom
sounds like uh it was it was more like
like did i even know what the phrase
public intellectual meant at 13 probably
not but
i knew i wanted to be a writer i knew i
wanted to be a famous writer i didn't
want to just like you know write for
myself i knew that i wanted to be
in the public i knew that i wanted to
talk about big ideas and
like you know it's just like that's what
i wanted to do and i wanted to do it in
an accessible way i wanted to be
i wanted to be on tv i wanted to be you
know on radio
and
and yes you're right look i had
immigrant parents and you know you can't
explain stuff like that to to you know
parents who gave up everything in order
to come to this country so that you
could have a better life
uh i've told this story before that when
i told my mom that i wanted to be a
writer
she said who's stopping you from writing
right like right right you can write
nobody is
you go be a doctor and then you write
and and i was like no i want to be a
writer like i want that to be a job my
job and she said that's not a job that's
not a real
job and so
you know that's how i went i got a
degree and i you know became an academic
because i figured well that's as close
as you get to
you know but even while i was getting my
degrees i was i was writing novels and i
was you know trying my hardest to kind
of uh become as much of the public
conversation as possible i had like this
very clear you brought up joseph
campbell that was me like i had a bliss
and i was following it and
yes i like you went through a bunch of
different hoops and
and you know some dead ends and some
u-turns
uh but i can say
that today right now in the year 2021
the year of our lord
it's 2022 reza oh [ __ ]
slight correction
happening [ __ ] idiot are you serious
leave me alone you got the year wrong
you just turned 50.
twenty twenty nineteen seventy two here
i am at 50 years old in 2022 and i can
say
without a shadow of a doubt
that i have followed my bliss
that i am doing what i was meant to do
what i've always wanted to do
i i made it this is where i am
that's amazing i i feel really
truly i feel the same way um i'm
i i hope that listeners aren't rolling
their eyes like oh these guys are
bragging because we're trying to get at
something here you know um
i
uh this is absolutely incredible i i
wake up with such chronic
dissatisfaction and i think this is such
a normal human
kind of uh response to the world i think
we survived because we have an anxiety
response to the world around us we have
survived as a species because of
rustling in the bushes might mean it's a
tiger and we need to be worried about
rustling in the bushes and so now we
don't have tigers eating us but we have
that anxiety over rustling in various
bushes happening
all the time this morning i needed to
order some dutch doors for an office
that's being built and i'm like i'm
we're never they're never gonna finish
the dutch doors in time
um with these with the
assembly line delays this is tara i was
i spent my entire morning
in misery over the idea that i had to
order these dutch doors so
but the but the point is is that i have
to through the tool of gratitude i wake
up in the morning and i have to remind
myself this is incredible rain
okay maybe you're not a movie star but
you've had an amazing career you're a
weird looking old dude and you had an
amazing career people love what you do
and now you get to write books you get
to travel you get to talk to reza um so
i have to remind myself that i am
in my bliss but these stories of how
people got there is so interesting and i
think the guest that we're bringing on
today
exemplifies this more than any other
story i've ever heard i mean this guy
stephen ho
um
you know essentially emergency room
nurse uh turned
comedian superstar with tens of millions
hundreds of millions of followers across
social media uh and it all has happened
so fast it's all happened in the last
two or three years i can't wait to see
what he has to say about this yeah and i
think we wanted to have stephen on the
program
because i think that you know what you
and i are talking about what stephen has
gone through is what i think a lot of
people are dealing with right now you
know what i'm saying because it's a
great resignation right the great
resignation exactly that we hear about
all the time i think a lot of people out
there are thinking to themselves
you know i had a dream and i kind of put
that dream away i had a bliss and i
ignored it
and
you know did the thing that i was
supposed to do or the thing that i
thought would bring me
you know
comfort and stability as opposed to
bliss and happiness and now i think a
lot of those people are looking around
and thinking to themselves
jesus christ you know i think if you
know now is the time am i if i'm gonna
make a change if i'm gonna follow my
bliss now is the time to do it and
here's this kid
stephen ho
who did it he's an er technician uh
you know in the middle of the pandemic
staring at death every day
and realizing that you know this isn't
this is not his bliss so
this is our big question
for today
how
do you follow your bliss
stephen ho
working 12 hour shifts in the er being a
frontline hero in the pandemic starts uh
making
funny videos using his kind of love of
comedy and his knowledge of hospitals
and these videos started picking up
steam
and uh
started getting noticed by everyone he's
got over 10 million tick tock followers
uh just millions of subscribers just you
know is it he's one of these new
celebrities the social media stars
um
and he quit it all quit quit the the er
game moved to la
got an acting agent continues to do
stand-up comedy
um it's a pretty inspiring fascinating
story let's welcome to the show stephen
ho aka
stevio
hi how's it going how are you guys
uh so just before you came on you uh
said that this was only the second
podcast you've ever done so i'm assuming
that you were living on mars until just
what like a couple of days ago no you
know people have been asking me to do
podcasts but i just you know i
i'm afraid i'm gonna say something
that's gonna go online forever that like
that i can't edit myself
so look we talked a little bit about
uh your journey uh to you know the place
where you are
now but uh why don't you take us back a
little bit so um you were an er
technician what by the way what exactly
is an er technician i actually i don't i
realize i don't know what that means do
you plug in the defibrillator
that's your job you plug things in no
it's no it's not really a technician i'm
so the emt is emergency emergency
room technician
that's essentially it was i was an emt
so you know i'd be in the er i'd help
out i'd uh set up uh procedures for the
doctor i would be on call for cpr i'd
clean out wounds um i'd wrap people up
help me get home i would do splints
which is to help you know
put fractured bones back together it was
an array of things that was essentially
the emt but in the er just a quick
question did you ever see something so
gross that it made you puke oh close
there was i've seen a lot but there was
one thing that made me gag and it was a
homeless guy
who came in
he had his
leg wrapped in a garbage bag and i took
it off and it was just flesh eating
maggots that fell alright thanks
thank you everyone good night
it's great talking to you stephen oh the
one thing that ever made me go
i've seen i've seen people's arms that
were falling off like calf muscles that
were hanging by like a
skin
but the one thing that made me just
nearly gag was maggots yikes
i can't believe you left that job anyway
uh
so the thing that i'm curious about
before we get to you know uh your
transition
is
how this came about like i mean what
what made you decide to become an uh an
er technician i'm assuming your mom made
you oh you're spot on sir
yeah
i can tell
you and me you and me i could tell it
was one of those situations where like i
knew i knew what i wanted to do but
you know my parents i mean it's just
it's such a like a cliche story my they
immigrated from vietnam in the early 80s
you know and when you're not from
america
getting an american education was like
the pinnacle was the best thing you
could do for your child so them risking
their lives three days and four nights
on a boat
right yep so when they got here like all
they want to do is get a job get build
up enough money to put their four kids
through university which they did
and they're like listen as long as you
get a degree any like
viable degree like science you're gonna
be fine so stop messing around go get a
science degree and go become like a
nurse or a doctor or something like
everybody else in this country right
this is an old story right right i mean
you don't you don't have to be just an
immigrant a lot of people have this
story where it's like you know you had
this dream about something that you
wanted to do and maybe it just seemed
impossible or maybe you just didn't even
know like how you go about doing it or
maybe it's pressure from your family for
one reason or another and so
you know you're going and that was the
thing like i didn't even know what it
was
that like i wanted like i was the the
pressure of them telling me to just to
get to college get a degree
wouldn't even let my mind wander to what
it could be right i was completely like
i don't want to say brainwash because
that's a little mean they didn't
brainwash me
but they essentially didn't let me think
about anything else
you know stephen something that
interests me so you have this dream um
and it has something to do with comedy
it has something to do with expressing
yourself it's it's characters and voices
and jokes and just this this longing
tugging at your heart and here you are
cleaning out the maggots from a homeless
man's leg
i'm not gonna stop with that i'm gonna
reference that about five or ten more
times are you kidding me this is
fantastic
i didn't know such thing was possible
that is really
gruesome and kind of exhilarating
but
take us through what happened here over
the last couple years because it's super
interesting you were a front line worker
and um before we kind of get again to
your your transformation and you you're
following your dream
front lines covered
you know 2020 2021 what was that like
yeah man it was
i mean it was rough
it
like i mean the er is already a pretty
you know hectic and stressful place
right
add on a pandemic where everybody
thought everybody didn't people thought
kovid was
radioactive
right i mean it's it was a deadly virus
don't get me wrong
but you know
if we had just
i mean i was like we messed up and tried
to like
tell people how and what to do
right there was a lot of like things in
the media that were scaring people like
the cdc was kind of going back and forth
with all these
rules it was just such a [ __ ] show and
and and what happened was in the er
we were trying to get everybody to stay
at home right if they would just listen
stay at home
like don't spread the virus it's gonna
be fine
but what started happening was you know
people started coming to the er for
these little things like say i don't
know if you guys remember back then it
was like i i went to the er
because i had a fever i think i might
have covet i'd like a cova test and it's
like well i mean you're not dying you
don't need a ventilator you're fine just
stay home wait for it to pass instead of
coming out and potentially infecting
other people with covid and getting
kovik coming into the er right it was
just it was
it was just this thing that was driving
everybody crazy
and like and and also on top of that
they're asking that when they come to
the er they would ask questions like was
this bed used for covet patients do you
keep covet patients in this building and
it's like oh yes like it's a pandemic we
have it's all over
yeah so that prompted me to get on
tick-tock and be like listen everybody
it was also a way for me to it was it
was an artistic outlet for me because
before all that happened i had a sketch
show i was doing comedy i i was doing
improv and that all shut down right and
i had no artistic outlet and then i
turned to tick-tock well and that's
because that's what i wanted to ask
steven like was it something specific
about that coveted time that made you
kind of
do
this transition to comedy on social
media it was some was it it was venting
it's because you couldn't go out to
comedy clubs yeah so it just kind of
came out sideways into tick-tock and i
imagine at the same time everyone for
the first time i'm i'm kind of guilty of
this myself i was like oh frontline
workers yeah there's all these people
wow in a situation like this they're
putting their lives at risk they're they
are on the front lines they're seeing
patients in in ers they're working
ambulances even the grocery clerks like
they have to be selling food to people
we can't starve and
i think for a lot of folks that kind of
their eyes were open and had a newfound
appreciation for
a lot of the workforce that
you know i hadn't really thought of as
heroes before but what was it
specifically about that time to make
this transition
i mean you know
everybody was kind of just locked up in
their their apartments like by
themselves right and i think that's when
tick tock really took off because we
couldn't go out so we were on our phones
a lot
and tiktok was just the new like it was
this new app that was booming
and everybody was trying to like get on
like hop onto the trend before you know
it got away from us like you know every
other social media platform or every
other app
so i i essentially went on because my
friend suggested hey like i know you're
bored at home and like you got nothing
to do you should make a tick tock i
think it's gonna be huge like great the
first three tick tocks had nothing to do
with coping
but after i picked up some steam i
started getting a little bit more
personable about like you know what was
exactly what was happening in the er in
my life
right um
and yeah it just took off because at the
time people people were hungry for what
was they needed they wanted to know what
was going on right the news was giving
it was the headlines of the news was all
like scared like everything was meant to
scare you and nobody had any idea right
and we were washing our groceries
remember when we were washing our
groceries oh my god i spent so much time
bleaching down my cartons of eggs my
sister would leave her groceries outside
of her apartment right let the covet air
off of it i'm like let it breathe
exactly
remember that you can get covered from
touching the gas station handles i'm
like what are you talking about
right
all this stuff that they were saying and
i'm like that's not that's not true not
just stay at home but wash your hands
and like you know
keep away from each other for a little
bit so you're surrounded by all this
confusion all this death you know fear
everyone is just you know nobody knows
what the hell is going on and you start
doing this you know these little tick
tock videos
they're fun they're funny
they're
informative you know they start to
become
uh popular
um
and at a certain point now now you're at
that place right where it's like ha
people are actually paying attention to
to me and what i'm doing here
um
i wonder like what what was it like to
kind of make that decision that okay
look this has been my passion all along
this has been my dream all along i'm i'm
removing you know uh maggots from
homeless guys uh leg because my mom made
me to do you know i was making her happy
it's making mom happy
uh
but here i am surrounded by all this
death and uncertainty
right so many of us were in that in that
situation we're reevaluating
our lives reevaluating the paths and
journeys that we've taken
and
is that kind of what the the feeling was
like for you where it's like huh
this is not just an opportunity now but
i i'm looking at you know my life and
all this death around me and i'm
thinking
i i you know it's time
yeah no it was definitely all of that
but it was also you know like i i've
been i was acting
before that for like
six seven years i think i did a lot of
theater
this was i was i've been waiting for
this opportunity you know it's one of
those things where i like yeah i know
what's happening here this is gonna be
big and i have to take advantage of this
but on top of that yeah it was also like
working with the er being called a hero
right and it was like we're getting
killed like this is not
what i want to do anymore you know i'm
not sure if i ever wanted to do it in
the first place yeah you're staring
death in the face yeah and here was this
opportunity
it was blowing up and at one point like
i was getting in trouble with my job
right they're like you gotta stop making
these videos like
could you go back to saving lives like
you're in the hallway they can make a
video
like code blue yeah that's exactly what
it is they're like hey they like they
somehow found out where you work the
internet mob is insane they found out
where it worked and they're like so my
job was like you got to start making
these videos so so i had a choice
at one point either stop making the
videos
or you know
stop making videos go back to work or
like leave the job and make the videos
cause you can't have both and at the
time i think i had maybe two million
followers across the board
but i just i just knew this is it i knew
this was like this was something that i
mean look that's a look that's a lot of
followers but it's that's a scary
decision isn't it like to like you're
getting a paycheck it was because health
insurance yeah all of that health
insurance paycheck my mom like what the
[ __ ] are you doing free jello freaking
selling all the jello you did
and also i was applying to nursing
school and if i wanted to get into
nursing school i needed
you know the job and the recommendations
from my bosses and nobody's going to
accept a guy who's screaming
[ __ ] to the world into like a
nursing program
so
um yeah it was just it was a lot a lot
that went into the decision
but you know i just wait when you know
you know i thought this was like my big
break right
so you you were doing comedy before and
then obviously now you're doing comedy
after but where does your
what is your comedic voice where does it
come from um there's immigrant story
and now on tick tock it's much more
about ers and the world of ers etc and
and nursing and health care but you're
branching out from there as well but how
would you define that voice and from
where it started what you went through
and where it is now yeah i mean i wasn't
doing comedy for too long i think i was
a year in and that you know the pandemic
happened but a lot of the stories was
about like being vietnamese living in
america my family having you know a very
strict mother
but now anytime i go on stage everybody
knows me as like stevio the [ __ ]
from the er so all they want to do is
hear about all they want to hear about
is our er stories yeah our stories yeah
so i've had to write which you want to
talk about comedy man you know suffering
death and sickness that's uh it's comedy
gold coffee gold yeah right so
um yeah i mean
i don't really even know
what it is right now i still think i'm
such a young i'm still young right up
two years in which if you ask like any
comedian they would think they would say
that's brand new still
yeah so you're two years in where where
do you see this going where do you want
this to go what what is your your dream
we're talking about finding your bliss
following your bliss
you know you started down this path
where does this end up i wanted i want
it all like i came to la i wanted to be
you know on tv like you i want to you
know be like
like part of the office like like me or
reza we're both on tv which one oh no i
think he's talking to you the office
i've been on tv a little more i i love
the office i mean we're actually talking
with uh some people right now we're
putting together a pitch deck to make a
mockumentary style show like the office
but in the er
hopefully have that oh nice that and a
pilot done by the end of the month so we
could pitch it to networks
nice oh fantastic good i better be
getting a call about that one stephen
yes you'll be the first one well steven
okay so you know i
i think this is an issue that honestly a
lot of our our listeners
are confronting right now you know
ray and i have talked about
you know what it was like for us to
follow our dreams
and you know the circuitous route that
we have taken
uh
in kind of you know getting to the place
where you know we always wanted to be
i think you know we talk a lot about the
great resignation you know that
people are
quitting their jobs you know and and
pursuing other lines of work and
um and i think honestly the pandemic
like in this you know as we as you we
were talking about the pandemic has
played a huge role in that i think a lot
of people are like you maybe not
literally staring death in the face but
are thinking about death all the time
and
and
are in that place where
you know they have the opportunity to
possibly
take a big jump quit the job you know no
more paycheck no more stability no more
health insurance and everything that
goes with it and to maybe do something
crazy
to follow their dreams to follow their
bliss
what kind of advice can you give
um people who are in that place i mean
you're on the other side of it now yeah
but go back to thinking about how scared
it you must have been
to to make that leap
and uh like you know what can you what
can you say to people who are in a
similar situation
like when i said when i was still
working as an er tech i was up at
stanford like six years but i started
taking
i
i started taking a theater class and i
loved it and i started doing
theater shows right and and i didn't
want to give up my job because i was
scared right giving up the stability you
know plus i was like applying to like
nursing school
so you know i was working 7 p.m to 7 a.m
going to school from 10 to 5.
right
i was working two to three days a week
going to school i was i was in a theater
conservatory because i like i loved the
first class and that's so i said i
applied for the conservatory
and then i was doing theater at night
but i mean what i'm saying is like if
you really want to transition out of
your
out of your day job to like whatever
your passion your bliss is
um
you know you can have to quit cold
turkey and go do it but hopefully you've
you've saved up enough to you know
mitigate any
risks that you're gonna take or you or
you do it like me but i did it both at
the same time and just kind of killed
myself luckily i was still in like my
mid-20s when i did it i would never
dream of doing it now
right but i mean if you're god if you
want to do it man like but here's the
thing too like
people these days i know like
the fomo is real because there's so many
people on social media who are blowing
up and and a lot of my friends who see
it
look at it and think oh this is easy i
could do this
right because that's that's what we make
it look like we make it look like this
is just life we're just filming life
but it's also like it's also a lot of
hard work and it's also like a full-time
job
so if you're not if you're not dabbling
it already don't just quit to go do it
try to maybe ease your way into it i
like i like what you're saying with your
advice you know i what i honestly what i
assumed that you were going to say was
just do it follow your bliss don't worry
about it it'll all work out and you're
like no actually listen maybe you should
make sure
let's see that's like that's the
immigrant mentality in me is speaking
again right like the vietnamese mother
and you'll be like are you sure you're
gonna be okay right like imagine that
right if
only it could be that easy where you
could just quit and do it and like for
some people they do they absolutely do
i've seen it work out but i've also seen
so many people who have like
you know they go they try and they
become bitter and it's ah doesn't it
just come down to like what you have to
do it's like what you have to do like
for me in acting like
i would still be acting if i wasn't
getting paid for it i was in fact my
wife and i were talking about in the
early 2000s before the office not long
before like do we move to like seattle
or minneapolis
and do i just do some theater and maybe
start a little theater company and teach
acting on the side and take some classes
and
you know because i just had to do it i
had to do it it wasn't a choice it
wasn't kind of like well i should set it
aside and i could i couldn't
do anything else i could not do anything
else i just had to do it but aren't you
saying that the acting bug for you kind
of worked in the same way i mean you
just would have found a way to keep
doing it even if you were 47 years old
and still doing like
kooky improv at thursday nights at
lulu's coffee house
you know then that's what you would have
been doing so be it after even after
you'd gone to nursing school yeah but
you know it's like again like it's like
but you have to make that realization i
remember when i made that realization
right like i'm gonna get paid the 20
bucks an hour for whatever the emt is
doing and i was gonna i had a sketch
show
right before the pandemic sketch show
that i loved i was doing comedy i was
getting five minutes and i was forced to
bring five people right i was so happy
and i finally thought oh my god if this
is all ever this is all it was
for the rest of my life like this is
what i want right this is it this is it
that's it
but i think like you have to come to
that realization that like this might be
it like right a lot of people go into
thinking like i'm gonna go to la
and i'm gonna be a [ __ ] huge star
next week
you know what i mean no so like i think
i i think
for me this is what i'm talking about
it's like not you weren't you weren't
you didn't do it to pursue fame you did
it because you had to do it it was part
of you and it brought you tremendous joy
so in this idea the old joseph campbell
idea of following your bliss it gave you
bliss even if you're doing five minutes
of comedy you had to drag five friends
there there were like 17 people in the
house you were like this is awesome i
could do this for a couple more decades
let's go let's get so
that i really admire that about you and
your story because the fame thing gets
really tricky and where social media
gets a little troubling for me as the
fame seekers on the talentless
fame seekers fortunately you had talent
you have talent you became famous
fortunately i had some talent and hey
guess what reza i became a little famous
too you not so much don't worry you'll
get there eventually i've actually never
been with you until this podcast right
so okay um but um but so that's the path
i always tell uh young artists and
actors uh that i speak to about like is
is just find the thing that ignites you
and that you just have to do you know
there's a great quote from the reverend
harold thurman that oprah winfrey always
quotes it says don't ask what the world
needs
and do that find what makes you come
alive
and do that because what the world needs
are more people who have come alive
and i like that idea find what makes you
come alive and do that thing and then
guess what
i don't know if it's the mystery of the
universe i don't know if it's just kind
of like general psychology i don't know
if it's god and fate in the holy spirit
but doors open up when you're doing what
you love because you're sharing joy
you're making other people joyful you're
providing a service and
your path will become more and more
clear oh yes amen amen i know
and again right like i i i have to
believe that right i i did at one point
i still do but like when we're talking
about people who are
like me who who are in a profession
who are a little older
right and who now are thinking like like
there's so much death people are dying
like maybe this is not really what i
want to do like i want to do something
else right
i think what i'm saying is that like
you know
go maybe
go dabble in it first
if if you really enjoy it then yes you
have to take that leap
but a lot of people like i think
ah
i sound so i felt like a terrible person
when i say stuff like this
i don't know i'm just like you know like
i'm so i'm still so cautious even now
i'm still so cautious
and uh i i i i i'm still learning
to break out of that myself too right
but i did at one point i did take i did
take the leap where i said listen i'm
done with the er you know i'm done with
this i'm done pleasing everybody i'm
gonna go do what i want
um
that was a big bold leap and i will tell
you that early on in my acting career
i saved a guy's life with the heimlich
maneuver oh so
we got that you could have been an er
technology you couldn't i could have
totally done it because we were having
alpine burgers at a diner on the upper
west side
and alpine burgers means they put swiss
cheese on it and
um we were laughing and laughing and he
was joking and turned bright blue like
robin's egg blue couldn't like blue is
this shirt
and i just did the old thing and boom it
flew out of his mouth
30 feet was that the first time you've
done it or
that was the only first and only time i
did it but uh
um
the dude uh i i got a little taste of
yeah i might yeah i might reza i might i
might leave the uh performing or i might
i might need to go to nursing school
follow you i felt
followed exhilarated
i felt exhilarated removing the alpine
burger from his gullet
uh stephen hill this has been a very
enlightening conversation and you know
it and like it's inspiring you know and
and don't don't worry about the fact
that you're still a little bit cautious
and
nervous that's just
that's called being the child of
immigrants that's just a normal thing
i'm still i still think that someone's
going to knock on my door and take me
away
i'm still like every time there's a
knock i'm like what is that for me
i hope they do yeah thanks thanks rain
uh but listen it's you know i think your
your story of following your passion
following your bliss and obviously
you've had enormous success is is a real
inspiration to a lot of people out there
who
who are kind of thinking about doing the
same thing right now and um it's
possible i mean if they're out there if
you're thinking about it let me tell you
it's possible just you know there's work
to be done though so be prepared
well listen um we brought you on your
second podcast ever
if i decide to go on the tick tock will
you
will you pop my tick tock cherry hell
yeah say that can peace say that
can we say that i think that's what
happens on tick tock you you pop
cherries
instead of follow is that how it goes
i i we could pop a cherry
on your first tick tock video oh my
goodness oh my goodness this is getting
this is getting very confusing but if i
decide to go on tick-tock will you bring
me on show me the ropes and help launch
my tick-tock career yes yes sir this is
not why we brought you on the show by
the way we love your story
we didn't want to capitalize on your
tick-tock fame that was my only goal in
this conversation and if i ever need a
an
epidural i'll i know who else to call
yeah 9-1-1 the hospital like what yeah
stephen's like not me don't call me
dad
yeah that conversation with stephen ho
it was enlightening for a lot of reasons
uh first of all i love how
you know you can you can take the
immigrant kid out of the er
hospital but you can't ever remove the
immigrant kid part like he's still like
yeah hey make sure make sure you've got
things lined up before you jump
right even for himself he's like i i
better keep things lined up
just in case just in case
uh yeah but you know one thing that it
made me think about rain is uh
yeah we're talking about how you and i
ended up where we are now and and you
know the paths that we have taken and
that we both followed our bliss and here
we are
in this in this place and i
i wonder just for fun like what if you
were to do something else right what if
is there like another bliss
behind your you know the bliss that
brought you here
a third bliss
let's assume there's another acting
the kind of writing talking thinking
about philosophical spiritual and
sociological topics third one there is
actually you know
football player nfl linebacker am i
right well i have been playing a lot of
competitive tennis recently but i am uh
i am a mere uh uh i am people don't know
this about you or you're actually quite
a a skillful tennis player i'm i am
mediocrity uh personified on the tennis
court but i'm pretty good i would kick
most listeners butts you know that's a
challenge folks
but but truthfully
um and i know i played a beet farmer on
a television show a long time ago but
there is part of me that would like to
get back to the land there is part of me
that
would
really enjoy
a farm in oregon
and having bees
and growing interesting things and
working the land and having animals on
that land and um
i i think that uh
this could be another bliss for me there
is there's uh there's an aspect of me
that is i'm very very social love being
in crowds i can put on a good show it
really uh excites me it innervates me no
enervates is not the right word
energizes me
um
but there's kind of i've got also a
hermit side of myself as well and um
you know i i
i
i'm saying goodbye to my penthouse and
going back to my plow basically i think
um
that could be deeply and richly
satisfying for me and
if this whole showbiz thing
continues to give me
headache after massive headache i might
just turn my back on the whole thing and
go wow
farm some bees farmer rain i can i can
see it i can see it you sort of kind of
look like a farmer actually
is it the beard or what the beer i'm not
sure holiday would be cool about it but
you know
centuries of farmers in my in my
background
centuries
norwegian farmers
going back
to the dawn of time what about you reza
is there you got a
a bliss beyond this bliss it's tough
it's tough because i i feel like you
know for better or worse i've
kind of single-mindedly been on
like i said earlier a path
that has brought me to this place which
is exactly where i
had planned
on being and here i am and so it's hard
it's hard but if i were to if i were to
really really think about it if there's
like another bliss that i
i i've had but i never really truly
followed see you're going to laugh
you're going to make fun of me if i tell
you i probably will yeah
at least you're being honest i
appreciate it that comes with the
territory yeah so tell me anyway i think
that maybe i you know would have liked
to be an actor
like you know i don't know come on
come on
oh
that's right i did a lot of i did a lot
of like you know uh acting when i was
younger i you know performed in in some
some theatrical what role some of them
serious some of them real did you did
you play like the water jug and beauty
and the beast or something what what
were the no but you played but i was a
uh i was one of the the little brown
kids in south pacific
uh for a big production of south pacific
yeah uh we sing the d temwa song i don't
know if any south pacific fans out there
no one nobody anyone anyone any south
pacific fans no no could i have been an
actor but here's here's what i will say
i've had i've spent a good deal of time
sort of behind the scenes you know in
the in the entertainment industry sure
yep and in the producer's chair yeah oh
man is it oh god is it hard to be an
actor oh jesus christ is it hard thank
you you're like wow
well you know you're already famous but
i'm talking about like those poor sacks
who just go from audition to audition to
audition
day after day
just you know getting shat upon
day after day after day
you know you finally get you finally get
your big break you get on set and
they're like uh the lighting isn't good
on you so we're gonna get somebody else
like what
uh it's just my heart breaks
for actors so if i were to be honest i
don't think i could do it i don't think
i could do it yeah it was i don't think
you could take the the the rejection and
the um
and the the the kind of the constant
whoring oneself out there so painful
i'll never forget driving my beat up
tattered volvo in 2002
um i had three auditions in the day i
had one like way out in burbank
one in like
down in like korea town and then one in
venice so i couldn't go home all day and
one was like i had to wear a suit and
look like a business professional and
one was like i had to be like a homeless
guy and one was i had to be a doctor and
they wanted you to have a doctor they
like said please bring your own doctor
bring your own stuff
bring your doctor white lab coat and i
had to go buy a lab coat i spent the
entire day in my dilapidated 1984 volvo
um
you know didn't get any of the jobs of
course and it was just
it was just soul-sucking yeah um so my
heart goes out to all the actors yeah
forget it i got it it's a tough yeah you
you wouldn't and i and by the way and by
the way i have no fantasies about
farming because i know how
hard that must be i can i mean i can
only imagine it's it's great in fantasy
you see biggest little farm you're like
oh that's so sweet but i mean come on
plows and moving rocks and fertilizers
and like cleaning up pig dung and
it's hot and you you know you've got
blisters i i i think it's got to be some
of the hardest work on the planet i mean
is it harder than acting i'm not sure
anyway
folks
what about you do you have a bliss
that's just calling you is it in the
back of your brain
just like
beckoning to you saying follow me stop
what you're doing follow me
uh or
have you done it i mean did you did was
the pandemic the moment in which you
realized okay
no more ignoring this siren call i'm
gonna go do it we'd love to hear from
you tell us all about it you can find us
on social media at reza aslan at
rainwilson and on twitter at
metamilkpodcast or on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake let us know about
your bliss
and who knows maybe we will add you as
the third host of the podcast
metaphysical milkshake if your bliss is
is being a podcast hospital we might
make it happen in that direction
hundreds of dollars per episode hundreds
and remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcast
and wherever else you listen to podcasts
thank you all my bliss lovers
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang you're not gonna tell
your parents
who survived a four-day boat trip to
come here with nothing
i i think i might be a comedian yeah
thanks for the sacrifice i'm gonna go
tell jokes and for seventy five dollars
a night
at the yup yuck's comedy not 75 bucks a
night you think i am like i'm getting
like i feel like
i'm getting a free drink and maybe like
some nachos maybe some nachos yeah
that's headlining sorry forgive me
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you